thank you
so what we know so far is the ukrainians
have been pushing right along this whole
front that they have with the Russian so
we start in the north from hakib or that
area pushing towards well we know there
have been raids by pro-ukrainian groups
into Russia near Belgard so that whole
area in the north and we've seen very
small gains we're talking sometimes as
much as a few hundred meters we are
seeing
a lot extended fighting heavy fighting
run backwards not back mode as we all
know is one of the oldest battles in the
Ukrainian War so far the Russians have
taken back a great cost but what the
ukrainians have started to do now is
their reinforced book north and south of
that town but it looks
possibly that the ukrainians may be
looking to use a pencil movement to
encircle backwood
but the main focus has been in the south
towards the parisia now we're seeing
Ukrainian advances in the South where
several small villages that owners have
heard of as of the last few days ago
these are little hamlets that have been
taken by Ukrainian forces as they push
South the problem is though the South
has been extremely heavily fortified by
the Russians these are some of the most
extensive and new dense fortifications
built by anyone in Europe since World
War II
[Music]
these are probing attacks shaping
attacks to see where it's likely the
Russians will be able to resist the
least and then it is likely that Ukraine
will exploit that area the most because
they have to get through these massive
and deep
fortifications it's going to take some
time for the ukrainians to be able to do
this I think everybody's expecting a
rapid lightning advance but that's not
going to happen and this is not going to
be the Cakewalk that some analysts seem
to think it is and there's going to be a
lot of hard fighting before there's any
kind of result